you know we have here in Nevada a lot of
Sun Nevada has 335 days of clear bright
sunshine there should be solar rooftop
systems on every house and every
building in this state we're going to
use the biggest nuclear reactor in the
universe the Sun which is right in my
eyes right now Nevada has some of the
best conditions for rooftop solar in the
country the cost of this particular
system is $37,000 installed twenty one
thousand five hundred thousand thousand
forty eight thousand dollars I had to
refinance my house to pay for this
and that wasn't I'm not a rich guy that
was like how can you just write a check
for 48 grand but the long-term plan was
it would pay for itself in eight years
in the late 90s Nevada's government set
up a policy called net metering net
metering meant that homeowners who
installed solar arrays could put surplus
power back into the grid if I put energy
on the grid it's used by Larry cheese by
Jason that's used by Ken doesn't leave
this cul-de-sac
now when I need energy back later in the
day when the Sun Goes Down I expected to
get back a kilowatt for every kilowatt I
donated for peak power which in other
words meant they got cheaper electric
bills my power bills were 330 dollars a
month and they went down drastically to
ten dollars and 15 cents a month Oh
everybody was so happy we help the
environment and we saved money at the
same time Soler's feature was so sunny
that in 2014
Solar City America's largest
manufacturer and lessor of solar panels
was welcomed into Nevada they removed
the upfront cost of going solar and
started leasing panels to homeowners
with zero down I jumped at the chance
immediately and so did a lot of other
people
so pretty soon 17,000 homeowners are
generating by coming in and basically
flooding the market with no upfront cost
lease
systems they basically woke up the
sleeping dragon I used some retirement
money to reduce my electric bill
permanently I thought in late December
Nevada's Public Utilities Commission
decided that solar customers were
mooching they weren't paying their fair
share to maintain the grid and Nevada
energy should charge them more if the
current plan stands I will pay more for
electricity for the next 30 years than
if I had not put this system on my house
you know they might as well just rip it
out of here Solar City quickly decided
that doing business in Nevada no longer
makes sense
but this isn't just a sideshow in the
desert it's a proxy war
you see Nevada energy is part of Warren
Buffett's business empire and Elon Musk
is behind Solar City and it looked like
Buffett's company had just secured a
victory
hundreds of solar homeowners came out to
protest the rate changes by the Public
Utilities Commission it doesn't make any
sense
design is bait and switch tactics
bringing the solar companies in only
love you and then taking them out to
Warren Buffett provide extra airplane
and some unusual collaborators like
actor Mark Ruffalo and a Tea Party
founder turned out to protest the Public
Utility Commission is the aunty I think
there is definitely a much larger issue
here than my house I think it's larger
than Nevada
I think if if the power company owned by
Berkshire Hathaway essentially
controlled by Warren Buffett can keep
their monopoly here can destroy rooftop
solar here that this is the example or
the precedent that they will take to
other states across the country and they
will try to kill the competition because
what you see there is competition for
the monopoly power company
if this PUC ruling will stand it has
effectively killed all you rooftop solar
installation in Nevada the thousands of
people caught in the crosshairs of these
billionaires are realizing that by
trying to do the right thing they might
have made the wrong decision Slenderman
the people spend so much money to build
all these and then one day they come in
they change the rules yeah that's the
biggest issue right now that is the
biggest issue right now because you
bought something on the premise that you
were going to save money this place here
340 days a year thousand percent agree
with you I was born and raised here
trust me I know
but it was it just doesn't make any
sense Warren Buffett huh I was pretty
good
but the environment has been left
completely out of the equation and it is
the environment that gains with all
these rooftop solar since the rally
Nevada Energy has suggested
grandfathering in existing contracts but
the rate changes are still in place
making it unfavorable for rooftop solar
it's not clear which billionaire will
triumph but what happens in Nevada may
just set the course for the rest of the
country